[Music]
all right what's up mkbhd here and along
with all the other stuff that's
happening in tech timber and tectober
2020 is also a new console release year
for both the big ones
so uh all the hype and fanfare and
excitement that comes from all that is
also upon us now i figured since i did
do a first look at impressions at the
ps5 when we got that announcement and
everything
it's only fair that i also take a look
at these guys too the new xboxes
and they are uh
very box like so microsoft sent over
these two new xboxes without the guts in
them and we know all the pricing and
availability which is actually more than
we knew about the playstation during
that video uh so this according to
microsoft is final hardware final
materials final design all that stuff
just without the computer stuff inside
so xbox series x will be 4.99 and xbox
series s
will be 299 both coming november 10th
and this is a bit of a different
strategy from what sony's doing with the
ps5 so we just got the playstation
prices as well for them it's 3.99 for
the digital only version with no optical
drive and 4.99 for the full ps5 and
other than the drive there's no real
differences between these two consoles
but with the two different new xboxes
here from microsoft as you can probably
imagine it's a bit of a different
strategy here for them to me a more
interesting launch strategy so here's a
high quality first look at these i want
to show them next to each other first of
all with some scale so we can understand
how ridiculously small both of them are
which is sweet but let's start with the
xbox series x so this is the flagship
it's the matte black box the main
console if i'm being honest it does look
pretty plain but that's what a lot of
people want under their tvs that's why a
lot of people don't want like an alien
spaceship looking thing but yeah matte
black everything here and i like it with
just the the slightest hint of green up
here in the top i think a lot of people
first saw that and thought it was a
light would have been cool if it was
lights but it's not it's just paint but
it is a pretty cool paint pattern inside
the holes here also side note no this
doesn't trigger my trypophobia but if it
does for you you probably shouldn't get
one you know sometimes the holes in some
weird things can be a little weird
looking i don't know anyway okay so as
far as uh the horizontal versus vertical
debate
i think the way this console is meant to
be oriented is vertical just because it
does have one giant fan here at the top
hot air rises and so that fan spins and
exhausts hot air at the top kind of like
the trashcan mac pro from back in the
day 2013.
but it also can technically be on its
side like this it does have a little
nubs at the bottom so if you want to fit
it under a tv or inside a little box
you've got your tv sitting on it can do
that too so horizontal or vertical it's
up to you also all the labeling for the
ports on the back are sideways as well
so it's totally fine being sideways
either way it's still just going to look
like a plain black box so optical drive
on the front with the eject button the
xbox logo is still the power button and
down at the corner at the front is the
usb port for controller charging and the
controller sync button for wireless
controllers then around the back it's
giving me two usb ports an ethernet port
storage expansion port and hdmi and
there's some more ventilation all across
the back here like a cheese grater and
even one more slot up here near the top
and that's about what we expected and
i'll we'll get to what's inside in a
second so then xbox series s here is a
matte white with a black circular
ventilation grille and honestly i really
like the look of this one here this is
probably my favorite looking out of all
the new consoles and this one's been a
little more polarizing we're not sure
yet how well this will stay white over
time will it yellow a bit or get dirty i
don't know
but i just think this one looks cleaner
and more modern maybe it's just me and
then again two possible orientations
here this one is it appears intended to
be sideways like this because again the
ventilation is coming out the top and
when we took it apart a little bit i
actually opened the bottom and it looks
like the cpu and the air cooler are
right underneath this so this is again
hot air rising ventilation goes out the
top like that but it does have the nubs
at the bottom so it can sit up vertical
and look like this little monolith that
it is there's also plenty of other
ventilation on each side with this one
plenty of holes and then on the back
there's ethernet two usb ports hdmi and
the storage expansion port again and i
can't stress how small this console is
it's the footprint is small it's it's
going to fit under a tv easily obviously
there's no disk drives here if it saves
a lot of volume there but yeah if it
weren't for the stuff i'm about to tell
you i would want to grab this
pretty much instantly over the series x
but as you may imagine there is more to
it than just the looks there are
different computers inside of each of
these microsoft is aiming to deliver the
same exact identical experience but at
two different resolutions and that's why
there's different computers required to
achieve each so xbox series x will
deliver 120 frames per second at 4k
while the white xbox series s will
achieve 120 frames per second at 1440p
and that
is what they're hoping to accomplish
that's the difference here so the rest
of the experience will all be identical
they'll both have the same eight core
cpu they both have ray tracing they both
do variable refresh rate up to 120 fps
but graphically of course less power is
needed to hit 1440p so the series s has
less graphical power a different gpu and
it also only has 10 gigs of ram instead
of 16. so my take is for most people who
don't have a 4k tv at the moment the 300
xbox series s is gonna be fine again 120
fps i think the frame rate as we can all
agree in gaming is more important now i
love myself a crispy screen of course
i'm a different customer but if you can
get it plugged into a high refresh rate
monitor it's going to look amazing it's
almost as portable as a laptop so
maybe not bringing it everywhere like a
laptop but the idea is fps over
resolution and also most people still
don't have a 4k tv but for people like
me who also really love resolution who
have a 4k tv already or who think they
might get a 4k tv in the next three four
five years when you have these consoles
you're probably going to want to splurge
for the series x
and then it will do 4k also and then
last but not least the series x has one
terabyte of storage and the series s has
half a terabyte of storage again they're
both expandable via those ports i showed
you but something to keep in mind if
you're getting the digital only version
so yeah the strategy of
offering a cheaper xbox undercutting all
of the currently available playstations
at least at launch anyway
is a really interesting one but then
again i also i wonder how many people
will actually buy the cheaper one over
the more expensive one because when you
divide out the cost of the console over
the three four five years you'll
probably have it
it's probably not that big a deal to
just go for the 200 extra dollars and
have the future proof console
uh so i don't know i i like the digital
only one i like the look i like i think
it's sleek but let me know what you
think in the comment section below which
one you would get or if you're in
playstation camp like i have been i'm
curious anyway that's basically it
thanks for watching also let me know
what you think of these shorter
impression style videos on stuff like
this in the comments below i'll be
hanging out down there okay thanks for
watching
catch you guys in the next one
peace